Herr Warner worked for Westwood One the
radio call last night of course the Hall
of Fame quarterback he joins us on the
program Curt thanks for getting up early
who was the big winner last night I
think especially fantasy football fans
at the fans that love to see a lot of
scoring they were the winners you know I
think the NFL won with that game and
they got an exciting game they got some
young superstars that showed up and
played well the game really had
everything and you know from the get-go
it was back and forth and up and down so
I think a lot of winners when it comes
to to the league and the fans it's a
copycat league we saw that when you guys
gave us the greatest show on turf can
you copy that like teams have tried to
copy Golden State it's not that easy but
you know the offense is we have with the
Saints and the Chiefs and the Rams are
putting up record-setting numbers is
this going to be something that
everybody's going to try to do well I
think everybody's gonna try to do it you
know the difference is with some of
those teams is the way to a quarterback
- playing first and foremost you have
quarterbacks that can bring the ball
down the field and be accurate and make
those big-time throws you know that's
what's different about those teams I
mean you watch those two teams last
night I mean they don't just throw these
you know short Dinkin don't throws they
will attack you down the field and they
both got playmakers all over the place
so uh yeah it sounds like a well let's
just copy that and let's do that but you
have to have the right personnel as well
and both of those teams have you know
talent across the board they have speed
and they've got quarterbacks that are
accurate down the field and I think
that's where it all starts if you're
gonna play that brand of football what's
there one rule change that brought about
this influx of offense
you know I don't know if there's just
one you know I think there's a couple
things I mean first foremost you know
when you're you're getting a flag called
on all of those you know bump and you
know hand fighting and they call it on
the defense almost every time I mean
that first and foremost
makes it difficult on any throw down the
field offenses are going to take more
shots because they're going to get more
penalties
I think the defenseless receiver rule we
saw that last night on a quick slant I
mean I thought it was a beautiful
defensive play knocking the ball away
from my neck of the woods in that
situation but you know I mean defenders
are sitting there going I don't even
know how to play when a ball is thrown
across the middle I mean a quarterback
leaves a receiver across the middle and
what you've always been taught to do is
separate ball from man and now if you do
that or if they don't catch the football
they're gonna call defenseless receivers
I think there's all kinds of rules like
that that you know really make a defense
second-guess and so when you got those
penalties and you got defense
second-guessing when you saw it last
night I mean it seemed to be guys wide
open nearly every single play but I
think there's a number of rule changes
we could go into being able to block at
the line of scrimmage when teams are in
man-to-man
so you set picks now and receivers are
blocking guys they don't even have to
pretend like they're running a route
anymore so I think there's a lot of
rules that that plate that the favour of
the offense is being able to do what
they do who would you rather have is
your quarterback mahomes or golf Wow man
sorry it's hard to say I mean they're
just a little bit different I mean I
love what here at goths doing from
inside the pocket and his ability to be
accurate down the field I think is
extremely rare but I think what's gonna
make Patrick mahomes
so special is he can make those shows in
the pocket but he's got a little of that
Aaron Rodgers ad-lib make the throws you
know off schedule and play more backyard
football then Jared I think can so I
think in every scenario you might you
might go with Patrick l'homme zone over
Jarrett if I said you could pick one of
these two teams or both these teams to
play in the Super Bowl not that that's
the matchup you want to see but what you
saw based on what you saw last night
which team more likely to be in the
Super Bowl
Wow that's a that's a great question you
know I think they're so similar in that
offensively they can do a lot of
different things and maybe la is a
little more balanced even though they
weren't last night running the football
and then both of them can get after the
quarterback upfront they're not they
haven't been great on the back end so
they're very similar yeah that's that's
a great I would love to see both these
teams flaky I mean I would love to see a
game like that again in the Super Bowl
but I think the Saints are going to have
something to say about that and I
wouldn't argue with that matchup you
know my homes against Brees either
because I think that would be phenomenal
good to talk to you occurred safe
travels home thanks for joining us you
bet that's Kurt Warner Westwood one
radio analyst NFL Network analyst and of
course hall-of-famer on the call last
night with Kevin Harlan and Edward Iran
Westwood won four more Dan Patrick show
to the audience Channel 239 on DirecTV
or download the Dan Patrick show app
[Music]